you
the Norwegian Nobel Committee has
decided to award the Nobel Peace Prize
for 2008 to Martti Ahtisaari for his
important efforts on several continents
and over more than three decades to
resolve international conflicts these
efforts have contributed to a more
peaceful world and to fraternity between
nations in alfred nobel's spirit
throughout all his adult life whether a
senior finnish public servant and
president or in an international
capacity often connected to united
nations artists re has worked endeavors
to resolve several serious and
long-lasting conflicts in 1989 to 90 he
played a significant part in the
establishment of Namibia's independence
in 2005 he and his organization crisis
management initiative cm I were central
to the solution of the complicated Archy
question in Indonesia in 1999 and again
in 2005 to 7 he sought under especially
difficult circumstances to find a
solution to the conflict in Kosovo in
2008 through the CM I and in cooperation
with other institutions after sally has
tried to help to find a peaceful
conclusion to the problems in Iraq he
has also made constructive contributions
to the resolution of conflicts in
Northern Ireland in Central Asia and on
the Horn of Africa although the parties
themselves have the main responsibility
for avoiding war and conflicts the
Norwegian Nobel Committee
has on several occasions awarded a Nobel
Peace Prize to mediators in
international politics today
Octus Ali is an outstanding
international mediator to his untiring
efforts and good results
he has shown what role mediation of
various kinds can play in the resolution
of international conflicts the Norwegian
Nobel Committee wishes to express the
hope that others may be inspired by his
efforts and his achievements